good winning everybody um it's really
nice to see all of you here usually I
have talks in much smaller rooms than
this I tend to talk about like really
nice things um so this is a treat for me
so let's start at the beginning um so in
2017 I made a little bit of a fuss about
election security and this was actually
the escalation of my fuss and then it
just got worse from here the worst worst
day I was on live television twice and
and recorded television once in the same
day okay fine I made a lot of fuss okay
and I didn't actually stop because it
sounds like when I say it in past tense
it sounds like I actually stopped making
fuss and I didn't but things have
happened since then this year for the
first time
Norway has regulations in place that
regulates the counting of ballots in
Norway so we've always been voting with
paper ballots in Norway but until this
year there was no audit of the vote and
a large portion of the votes in Norway
were only counted by computers this year
we have a regulation in place finally
after a lot of a lot of writing on the
internet and that at least one of the
counts has to be manual and it is
specified also that manual actually
means by people and not by machines and
on Monday we will have our first
election in Norway with this regulation
in place but another thing also happened
on January 1st Norway's new National
Security Act went into effect and for
the first time the actual counting of
ballots or voting systems in general are
considered to be
concerned for national security and
therefore NSM the Norwegian security
agency actually has purview to to look
at and study and and audit election
systems in our way so this will have
profound effects on election security in
Norway for the foreseeable future unless
somebody messes it up in the political
process which is always an option but
the thing is the one thing that I want
to talk about today is not any of those
things I want to talk about the fact
that nothing happened
and and this is true for the eggs of the
entire world nothing really happened in
2017 or 2016 that made elections less
secure and this is an important fact yes
things happened I'm not saying things
didn't happen but nothing made it less
secure in 2016 than it was in 2015 or 14
or 13
we just got scared and fear has has a
great effect in IT security fear gets
you money fear gets you meetings
fear gets you gets you the resources to
do the things that you need to do it
just felt more likely all of a sudden
that someone will meddle in our
elections didn't feel like a conspiracy
theory anymore but let's have a game so
we're going to have an election this is
going to be for the president of Norway
we don't have one so it's about time and
and you can elect either the turtle or
the hare we will do it here by a show of
hands and so we will start the election
so hands up anyone who wants the turtle
for president
okay and the hair okay and I will give
you the results are you ready of course
none of you actually believed that I
just now scanned the audience and
counted all of the hands and actually
actually having scanned the audience the
results are quite accurate actually but
but you wouldn't believe me right doing
this but let's say that I put up a bunch
of cameras on stage filming all of you
and then having you and having like some
kind of animation so you could see the
picture of the audience and I would have
some like image recognition I would zoom
in on the hands I would maybe have some
like really nice graphics that would go
like very dynamically up and down as it
was like counting and then I would give
you the results okay chances are a bunch
of you would actually believe me and and
and that's not bad because I couldn't
make that I can build that and but you
know what's really easy is to fake that
and that's the problem because who can
you trust
maybe I wasn't the turtle maybe the
turtle is my turtle who is feeding you
the data and what are their motivations
so the talk is called trust and critical
infrastructure elections elections are
central to this talk but I want to pull
some lessons from elections so I'm not
going to talk so much about Who I am but
you know you can google me I guess and
so Mac plays professor Matt plays is one
of the foremost experts of election and
security in the world has written lots
of things on it has also testified
before Congress in the US and this is
one of many tweets in the same
vain I've said it before I'll say it
again I've been working in security and
large-scale systems for over 25 years
civil voting is by far the hardest and
most complex problem I've ever
encountered and this is what I struggled
to explain to people and so I will try
to explain it today because complex like
if you think about it it doesn't sound
so complex is it Norwegian election
system so complex not really
so I'll read you a quote this is from
masters thesis and this is from the
abstract of that master's thesis
it says the testing is performed using a
prototype implementation in Java though
the implementation does not take into
consideration security and anonymity
concerns it is a full implementation of
the electoral system and when we talk
about an election electoral system
electoral system is actually a system of
systems is a distributed system with
many different types of systems
communicating with each other and that
could be the the system that is used to
to register the candidates that are
going to go on the ballots all the way
to a system that is to display the
results of the election and there are a
multitude of systems in between this
master's thesis was to evaluate the
transport of data from different types
of systems using an XML standard which
was called EML election markup language
and I was testing it for the Norwegian
laws and regulations with regards to
elections to see if it was possible to
do to express it with email and and and
I want to to really put an emphasis on
the sentence though the implementation
does not take into consideration
security and anonymity concerns it is a
full implementation of the electoral
system the prototype itself was only
written in a few weeks it was a
distributed system with with a fantastic
interface for internet voting
was a terminal interface I'm sure it
would be very popular um but it was
written just in a few weeks so the
system itself that the the idea of
voting is not very complex it doesn't
have inherent complexity just the system
itself and I can say all of this because
this was my master's thesis and it
wasn't hard and you can read it online
if you want to and people have gotten
paid to read my thesis which I feel is a
win but I want to put an emphasis on
this security and anonymity concerns
because this is the problem and this is
what makes elections so hard so what are
these it's complicated and let's start
from the beginning what are you actually
protecting the worst case scenario when
it comes to a manipulated election is an
accepted but manipulated election result
the idea here is that the population and
the previous government will all accept
a result that has been manipulated we
will believe it to be authentic but it
is not another very important term here
is the election result and we need to
talk about what that means an election
result is the distribution of mandates
so election doesn't have to be flawless
in any way you can have lots of errors
in an election as long as the election
result is correct so if we go back to
our election previously this was a
majority vote we could have all sorts of
flaws here as long as the turtle wins
you can have a thirteen percent error
and you will still have
the same election result and this is
something that people find hard to
understand sometimes when talking about
elections they say yeah but people the
people make mistakes when counting and
we'll get back to that people yes people
do make mistakes when counting we all
know that we've counted before we have
personal experience and but the
likelihood of it affecting these
election result it is very small and
we'll talk about why later then we have
to talk about what is the threat model
for elections what are we actually
afraid of what are we afraid that people
will do we are afraid they'll add
ballots take vows away change them maybe
just pretend the count was something
else than it actually was
maybe not count at all but at its most
extreme we are trying to prevent a coup
and that is what will happen if you have
an acceptable manipulated election
result you will have had a coup there is
no longer a democracy the the voice of
the people was not heard someone else
chose who would take power but who are
the threat actors who are the ones that
might want to meddle in an election the
most likely threat actor and this is
surprising for many people and an
extremely central to election security
the most likely threat actor both
historically and internationally this is
for like looking back hundreds of years
or just looking back to last hundred
years it is the sitting government
people keep on talking about like Oh a
foreign government through meddle in our
elections but the most likely threat
actor to meddle in an election globally
today last year all over the world is
the sitting government it's almost
always the sitting government that
manipulates an election of course there
are other ones foreign governments
private companies terrorist activists
lone wolves a government that has been
active in meddling in other countries
elections is the United States long
history of meddling in the democratic
process in other countries private
companies also in the in large parts of
the third world you've had private
companies meddling into democratic
process but the most likely threat actor
in an election is the sitting government
and that is important because this is
the same government that's running the
election and this makes elections really
hard because you can say oh yeah but I
can protect the system I can protect the
system yeah but you are the one that
can't be trusted the people who are
writing to the logs the people are
reading the logs that people are writing
the systems that people are running the
servers the people who are deploying to
these servers they are the most likely
threat actor another thing that is
surprising about election security is
that there are two acceptable outcomes
you can have a correct election and
great and everyone's happy but it's also
an acceptable outcome if you prevent it
a rigged election so actually
discovering and preventing this coup
from taking place is an acceptable
outcome in an election security
unfortunately this isn't always as easy
it comes with footnotes
because the problem is can you recover
from that situation as it stands today
most election experts in the United
States think that the u.s. election
system cannot recover from a
manipulation in Norway I don't think
that is a problem I think we have paper
ballots we can we can probably do a
recount large parts of the US they have
no paper ballots there is and even doing
a recount might not be feasible so this
is it is a problem and something that
that election experts in the US are
worried about but another aspect I
talked about security and anonymity
concerns so let's talk about anonymity
concerns because whenever I talk to
anyone who likes computers about
election systems and they come like yeah
yeah but you can just do this I love how
like we have a tendency to throw the
word just out there it's ok you just um
the first thing they sacrifice in their
theoretical model for solving elections
is anonymity that is always like the
first yeah but you know how like ah so
how does a secret ballot play into
elections because it plays in on many
levels a true democracy requires the
freedom of all of us to vote our
conscience this might seem like like a
silly thing to say like of course it's
true but it isn't most of us will keep
certain things private and some of us
will have opinions that we don't want
people maybe at work or even in our
families to know that we have so we've
had we've had breaches of all sorts all
sorts of personal information that has
been has come online what if you were
afraid that there would be just a breach
somewhere and suddenly your boss would
know that you're voting for the
Communist Party or something else
the problem is the moment people are
afraid that people other people might
know what they voted people start to do
strategic choices they will make they
will say okay I won't do this because
I'm afraid somebody will find out so
I'll do say fit a little bit so we so
people have to feel free to vote their
conscience but we also want to prevent
coercion and coercion is trying to make
somebody else vote something they don't
want to vote coercion is very common in
workplaces for example your boss will
tell you what to vote but also in
families where where one person and the
family will dictate that everybody else
has to vote a certain way we also want
to prevent vote selling and both of
these depend on one thing if nobody
knows what you voted and you can't prove
what you voted
then no one can check if someone's
trying to coerce you to vote against
your conscience then you can just walk
out and say yeah I did what you said
there's no way for them to check and so
they can't beat you up or fire you
because they can't check votes selling
is the same thing why would I pay
somebody to vote a certain way if I
can't actually be sure that they voted
the way I want we also want to prevent
persecution we don't want people to be
persecuted for the way they voted and
you think yeah but I'm not wearing like
this government is never going to
persecute me for the way I vote yeah but
what about if we suddenly have a fascist
government in ten years they have the
same data now they can put you on those
lists
so persecution doesn't have to be now it
could be some other time and it can even
be that it just it was a breach and this
data was leaked online and then suddenly
now you're on somebody's list terrorist
organizations list for example so we
kind of have to go there the answer is
not the blockchain I can't I cannot I
can't like skip over that in this talk
or else if we I will be stuck on Twitter
forever and so we'll go there just a
little bit to prevent persecution we
already talked about that you don't want
to connect a vote to a person we don't
want there to be a list on who voted
what anywhere there is no thrust a
trusted third party here to prevent
coercion and vote selling you don't want
a person to be able to prove what they
voted if you can prove what you vote
then you can sell your vote this is very
and we can make a system - we can make
computer systems for this and actually
who put what what is the thing that put
that vote on the blockchain and who's in
charge of that
and what about chain of custody of those
votes and this is where you see an
analysis of computerized voting again
and again and again it always breaks
down somewhere around there but let's
talk about this man versus machine
because I don't hate computers I love
computers
I would like done nothing but for like
close to 20 years now um but manual
elections have so many features that are
really really hard to be currently there
is no known solution that is better and
more transparent and more auditable than
in a manual election and and we have to
also realize that that manual Elections
has spent like hundreds and hundreds of
years being perfected in life the most
crazy small ways you can have for
example you have the concept of a ballot
box which can contain lots of ballots
now you think that okay yeah but it's
just like convenience because you have
to put them in something and and
everything it is a part of the anonymity
chain because if you have to put your
vote your ballot in a box full of other
people's ballots then it will be mixed
together now it's like yeah your vote is
one out of a thousand before it even
gets to anybody's hands so it's already
messed up and you can see that process
it's visible to you when you put it in
all of these things are a part of the
audit ability of a manual election which
has been designed to be that way they're
just that good okay but isn't manual
counting really slow surprisingly no and
and of course when you think about it it
makes sense right it's massively
distributed if you have polling
locations everywhere and that is also a
feature of manual elections you can have
polling places everywhere because you
don't have to centralize it because you
don't have to buy the servers and
everything so suddenly you cannot
polling places in every Church in every
school you can have them close to people
suddenly now people can actually have
access to vote because they can get to a
polling location it's not something they
have to take a bus to that will take
them hours out of their day just to go
and vote it's massively distributed
because you do it locally
at the polling place is manual
accounting error prone yes yes I know
it's complicated so let's look at that
so this is a risk model for Norwegian
ballot counting so this is we're going
to see the risk model for ballot
counting errors man versus machine so we
need some things here to be able to
measure the risk or to evaluate the risk
so we have to figure out what is going
to measure our severity and and risk
like traditional risk evaluations and
security you have severity on one axis
and probability on another axis so
something is really severe and really
probable you kind of have to do
something about it but very often those
things are eliminated because people are
not going to live in a world where there
is a high probability of bad things
happening they will generally do things
about those things but how you evaluate
severity is first of all can it affect
the election result if you can't then it
doesn't really matter can it go
undetected because okay if we can affect
the election result will we notice if we
can't notice that it happened then that
is really bad right
can it discredit the election result but
now we're moving down it's like yeah it
can happen but what do we do it becomes
more of a political problem but it can
be come a huge problem and this really
depends like revolutions have started
based on an election result that people
do not trust if you have enough conflict
already in society and an election
result is somehow discredited even
falsely it can lead to physical violence
even to to civil war
and then last is I cannot create more
work and that means do we have to like
let's say that you have to do a manual
recount about all of the votes or things
like that it will create more work it
will take more time yes but it's not
that bad so how do we evaluate the
likelihood how normal is it like how
often does it happen do we have any data
that we can measure like how common is
it and is it a known threat because that
will also change like you might say that
okay suddenly we're getting actual data
coming in that there are people trying
to do something now suddenly all of the
probabilistic this will change right so
then we can put it into like this risk
diagram and here are my evaluations for
a Norwegian elections so likelihood to
have an innocent so innocent in this
case is just you didn't mean to but you
counted wrong so manual counts are wrong
but nobody really meant to do anything
bad hi likely it's just because we all
count wrong
counting enough ballast you're going to
have an error rate there has been
measurements of this um in the US you
have really complicated ballots and they
have four Norwegians said this might be
like really weird but they have
basically a multiple choice ballots and
they can have like up to 80 contexts and
contests on one singular ballot and it's
really complicated often times people
actually miss elections because they
thought there was instructions and
things is like you have usability
concerns with the ballots and US ballots
are really really hard to count because
you actually have to go through and
check what did people what did people
actually check off Norwegian ballots are
really easy because the ballot
represents the party the party has the
list on it you can make alterations like
manually but almost nobody does it's
like 1% of the ballots so 99 of them is
basically counting paper so it's really
easy
and so so very informal examinations of
numbers in your weight around 0.02 to
0.1 percent error rate and counting ish
but we need actual formal examinations
of this but yes there will be errors but
they won't be much premeditated and no
matter if it's manual or machine I am
counting the likelihood in Norway to be
low and that is basically something that
NSM will have to evaluate whether that
changes but I we don't have a lot of
history for this year but when it comes
to machines innocent
err counts Eric well erroneous counts
I'm counting that I'm putting that at
low to medium and that's basically those
kinds of things would be bugs and
practically every single election we've
used computers in Norway for the past 20
years or more we have had bugs
discovered on Election Day or after
every single election and practically
all of them were discovered by accident
an example was there was a candidate who
got a extra person votes and he got a
lot like he got like a hundred and
twenty and people were like who is this
guy and it turns out that he was getting
these extra votes because people were
writing his name apparently on ballots
but everybody was like why why haven't
we ever heard of this guy he's this
popular right so they went back and they
looked at the ballots and actually
having he had gotten zero so then they
had to go and looked at the software
that was doing that the character
recognition and what they found out was
that it had a bug that when you wrote a
name if you had any kind of letter that
went to the line below like a G or J or
some
then it would think that something was
written on that line and since it wasn't
able to to figure out what it was it
would pick the first candidate
alphabetically and that's just one out
of a lot of books so then we go to
severity what is the severity and and
the most surprising here is probably the
low because I'm saying that an innocent
manual erroneous count the the severity
is low because this distributes
proportionally so let's say that you
have a thousand volts and you're going
to make a mistake in counting 20 then
that will scale with the number of volts
a party has so a party that has lots of
votes will have more errors and a party
that has few votes will have few errors
chances are it will not affect the
election result now there are there are
exceptions to this especially in close
elections and in Norway today we don't
really have good election regulations
regarding close elections some states in
the u.s. they do so they will say that
if the election is this in this close we
will do a manual recount and we don't
have that in Norway but but but that is
a risk there in really close elections
and when it comes to severity of
premeditated it manual manual
manipulations it is a medium because
well there actually it could be low like
first of all it's most likely going to
be a detective the problem is is really
hard to go into a polling place you have
to physically be there and also to be
able to manipulate the election results
you have to be in many polling places so
now suddenly you have to have a
conspiracy you have to have lots of
people involved it's a very big chance
it's going to leak somehow and all of
these people have to be physically
in the polling location and they have to
basically do the manipulation in front
of other people very likely that they
will be as seen and and you see this a
lot in manipulated elections in many
many countries that have tradition for
many fellate elections everybody knows
they are manipulated it's not a secret
everybody knows they you can walk into a
polling location and you see people
replacing ballot boxes is like and
somebody will just take it home it's
it's not like it's a secret and so so
the problem there is that nothing will
change that you are in a rigged system
there's there's nothing in the election
process that will fix that and nobody's
respecting the election result it is
rigged but in a true democracy people
will find out and most likely find out
and you can actually invalidate the
election result the problem is people
have touched the ballots so in a manual
election and you have you find out this
polling location people have men have
been trying to manipulate the election
result can you trust the physical
ballots anymore
most likely no so that makes it hard
also because you can use this right you
can say okay so fine we're going to
ignore all of the results from this
polling location because we know people
were trying to do something there but
now you can basically use this as a
denial of service attack because you can
go into let's say you're like a
predominantly liberal neighborhood and
you will do it a very visible
manipulation there so all of their votes
will be discounted so yeah it's an issue
when it comes to severity of machine
erroneous counts when it comes to a bug
this very me is medium to high medium
because usually with bugs they like they
act weird like they do like weird things
and they have a tendency to be very
consistent and and you you saw an
example of that in Norway
where the labour party didn't get any we
do weird things but you can check off
next two names um don't worry about it's
like weird Norwegian things that you can
do um but but basically they thought it
was weird that nobody got anything in
the second column on the ballot but that
only well they didn't think it was weird
nobody actually reacted the the the
results were finished and accepted when
a guy who was in the second column on
the ballot came and he said okay there's
something weird here because you say I
got no none of the checkmarks but I know
I must have gotten at least one because
I did it myself and so then they go and
they check the ballot and it turns out
that there had been a font change so one
of the one of the columns had gone too
bold which had shifted it a little bit
so that the check boxes were no longer
read by the character recognition
software and so all of the people in the
second column all of their check marks
had disappeared and so of course they
had to go back may change this bla bla
bla reread all the ballots but the
problem is that so so on the good side
bugs have a tendency to be like very
visible because I have intends to do it
for all of something unfortunately they
are generally only because nobody is
actually until now
nobody is actually auditing the election
there it's only discovered by accident
so most bugs will probably never be
discovered when it comes to the severity
of a premeditated so now we're coming to
somebody hacked the election type thing
the severity is very high because the
chances are they are going for this to
be covert right there might only alter
like a few percent of the votes and
because it's a single point of failure
you're just going for the computers you
don't even have to be physically present
you can sit at home in your country and
do this and and you could in or
by the way because 203 companies that
were licensed to install ballot counting
systems in Norway were not Norwegian
companies and at least one but probably
more than one had remote access software
to do support so you could stay at home
you know and do this and it's safely in
the bunker in your own country okay but
using this let's put them here because
this is where it gets weird so the
likelihood of innocent manual erroneous
counts is high but severity is low and
if you look at this things suddenly
suddenly realise that this is not as
symmetric as we would think innocent
machine counts is actually much more
severe although less likely so what can
we do
can we have manual elections what
security professionals in election
security have come up with and this is
not new is something called software
independence it was mentioned in a paper
by Ron Rivest who's the our and RSA and
John P wack and software independence is
quite simple a voting system is software
independent if an undetected change or
error in its software cannot cause an
undetectable change or error in an
election outcome this is not a technical
definition right but it is it it is
fundamental in understanding what we
need and now the goal is how do we
achieve this how do we achieve that it
is not undetected
and it is from this paper called on the
notion of software independence and
voting systems so what we need is audit
ability and we know this from from
software as well we call it
observability it is the same idea we
need a way to see if it is right somehow
to verify the election results not the
voting system this is from the same
paper so what we need to check is that
the results are correct because the
thing is at the end of the day like I
said before you don't know what software
is running I might like write all of
this software for all of this like hand
recognition software and I can give it
to you I can open-source it you can
review it you can do all of those things
you can all say oh yeah it's very secure
it does all the things it's like nothing
but when I'm actually standing here and
showing you like the fancy graphics and
the results you don't know what's
running so what we need to figure out is
a way to audit the the results not the
system but when we talk about manual
elections what does that really mean the
first part of a manual election will
always mean paper ballots you need
something for people to count and you
need some kind of record of what people
voted and a manual count you can keep
computers I'm not saying that people
come to me and they go like Patricia do
you hate computers as I can't we use
computers for elections are you going
back to the Stone Age no you can keep as
men like many computers as you want as
long as I can be sure that the results
are what people vote it
and then you have instead of manual
elections let's talk about auditable
elections we still need paper ballots
but we need a manual audit we need a way
to check it and we need a way to check
it that can be done by people and by
people who are not experts we need a way
for regular normal people to be able to
check that these results are correct we
need a way that we can train thousands
of people to do this because we need
thousands of people to do this so we
need a way that I can teach somebody in
10 minutes what to do and they can do it
and they can understand it and they can
walk away feeling confident that the
things were correct
so if we add an audit what how does that
affect this risk model an audit will
reveal both bugs and manipulations and
most of the time it doesn't really
matter which it is because suddenly an
innocent machine counting error will be
discovered and it is as likely as it was
before but now you can actually address
it it won't go hidden and a premeditated
attack will still be as likely as it was
before but now again we can discover it
and address it and the good thing about
a machine count which is manipulated is
that nobody has touched the ballots you
can just go count them just go count the
ballots manually there there's it's
really easy to recover
so how can we do an auditable election
so this year we get a manual preliminary
count in Norway we have two counts I
call one in a preliminary count and one
a final count it has now for the first
time the first count has to be manual
all over Norway all of the ballots will
be counted manually so now you have you
have one manual count and then the
second count there is a high likelihood
it will be counted by computers um you
can ask me about how we got here it's a
long story but but one of the things
that is important to realize here is
that okay so now we have a manual count
and we have a machine count okay this is
as far as we've gotten in Norway it's
take me 2 years
so we still don't have a process for
dealing with what happens if they're not
the same what matters if they differ
greatly and it was funny because when I
was in the middle of this and they were
pulling me on television for two years
ago and a guy who was that who until
recently was the head of IT IT
organization in Norway yes he told me ok
Patricia are gonna go on TV you're only
going to be able to make one point maybe
two so you need to sit down and figure
out what are the two things you want to
say because that is all they're ever you
are ever going to be able to communicate
on TV so I basically talked to myself
for like three hours and then I called
them up on the phone and I said okay we
need a way to to know if there has been
a manipulation we need some way to
discover it and number two if we
discover it we need to do something
about that currently we're number one
there is no process in Norway for
dealing it with it if these two are in
some way different we even don't even
have a definition of what different
means
but everyone is sure of is that they
will differ because Immanuel Kant will
have manual errors and there might be
machine errors as well so we know there
will be different but what is two
different we have know nothing for that
but in the US this gets more complicated
so the goal for many US researchers
today is risk limiting audits so step
number one in that process you have to
have manual ballots you have to have
paper ballots that people can count
manually but they will most likely be
counted by machines so what you need is
some kind of manual audit of the paper
ballots taking a percentage of them and
checking them to make and what they want
to do is validate the results that the
Machine this came up with so basically
saying how likely is it that the count
was correct and the good thing about
risk eliminating audits if we imagine
again that we've voted here and ninety
percent of you according to my machine
says that the turtle should be president
ten percent of you says the hair that's
what my system says ok a way that you
can manually manually do risk limiting
audit of that is just take a random
sampling of the audience so just take
like ten people put them in a line and
just ask each one now if all ten of
those say hair something's hinky and
you're like okay I could be like really
really unfortunate right now so in a
risk limiting audit you'll just grab
more people and now you'll ask everybody
again and you will continue to grab more
people as long as the results seem
unlikely until worst case this
degenerates to a full manual recount so
this is a process where you can
generally count very very few votes and
be pretty confident of the results
and that's all it is this is a
statistical model for manual ballasts
something it isn't very complicated and
it can be done by people and you don't
have to train people for four months or
years this is something that normal
people can do last year I was fortunate
enough to be the Allman's thesis advisor
where she she looked at error detection
mechanisms in Norwegian elections and
her thesis is available and and if this
is something you want to study further
than then please read it but what was
the fundamental problem that we had in
our way
we didn't have any audit we had large
parts of the ballots most likely for the
the election in 2017 the plan was most
likely because we don't have precise
numbers and getting them is really hard
most likely about half of all ballots in
Norway we're going to be counted only by
computers until I made an fuss I made a
large fuss ten days before the election
they issued an emergency regulation that
said all ballots in Norway had to be
counted manually at least once so it
didn't happen but that was the plan
and that was the plan until the
regulation this year as well and there's
a cheat in this because the Norwegian
government pays for these systems all
are all of the community in Norway so
all of the municipalities in Norway get
this software for free they never pay
for it but if they do a manual account
or anything regarding the money account
they have to pay for over their own
budgets
so for them locally it will seem cheaper
to the use computers for this um but
nationally I'm not sure that's true we
have a whole Directorate that is
dedicated to just making election
systems in Norway this Directorate is
under the government the sitting
government reporting directly to the
current sitting government so paper
ballots are not enough there's
start-button not enough you have to have
an audit and it has to be able it has to
be done by regular people if you just
have a plain normal like manual account
at election then it has a built in on it
it's people people don't trust other
people it's like you put two people next
to each other and and they vote
different parties and now they're gonna
count ballots like they're gonna be
checking each other it's like it's like
oh you see doing anything hinky people
are naturally suspicious of other people
but people are not naturally not enough
by far and that includes us and
suspicious enough of computers it's like
oh no it was a computer it must be fine
computers are our objective right it's
like there can't be any kind of bias
built into computers Canon it's not like
we can actually you know like write
things and make computers do other
things is it so Manuel captain encounter
the elections can also be rigged yes
they can but when they are everybody
knows they are
so the question is if an election is
rigged and nobody knows do you have a
democracy of course not you've had a
coop you just don't know but let's take
a step back and look a little bit at
this at a broader perspective outside of
elections what could an attack on
another type of critical infrastructure
look like and we saw an example Stuxnet
there are many interesting facts about
Stuxnet but the most interesting fact I
think in 2019 is that it came out in
2010 that's nine years ago they think
the development of Stuxnet started in
2005 that's 14 years ago Stuxnet was an
attack on Siemens PLC's and centrifuges
and an Iranian Iranian Iranian uranium
enrichment plant okay it was an attack
on an embedded device it was an attack
to cause physical damage
they recorded data the malware recorded
data for a long time
diagnostic data good data for weeks and
when the attack was performed they
replayed the good data so everything
looked fine we think probably hundreds
of centrifuges were destroying some
people think it delayed Iranian Iranian
Iranian enrichment for at least two
years
it cost tremendous amount of money and
it took a very long time to realize what
was going on now we can feel however we
feel about like Iran having nuclear
anything but what we saw here is an
attack that we had never seen before and
it came out in 2010 and one of the
things that I want you to notice and if
you want to read about it you can read
this book by Kim setter it's awesome but
one thing I want to point out is this
part the diagnostic data was manipulated
so the people who were watching these
machines didn't understand what was
going on because everything looked fine
and what is really modern life today if
not completely ruled by critical
infrastructure and what is critical
infrastructure anyway but we have power
we have have have internet we have water
we have waste disposal we have all sorts
of things that if it breaks down modern
society will break down really rapidly
and what we've seen now in this current
cyber war that is going on for example
in the Ukraine is that this is exactly
what they're going for they're going for
shutting down power shutting down
internet because modern society is a
legacy system it wasn't really designed
it kind of just got that way we had
water treatment plants then we put them
on the Internet we had power grids and
then we put them on the internet it's
based on layers of data technology and
of course it would be because it's too
expensive to be able to change it out
all the time so you have to this is this
isn't a flaw this this is how it's
always going to be whatever is modern is
going to be legacy and it contains
massive technical debt because unless
you get the priority you can't do the
investments you want to do it lacks
holistic security analysis what happens
if power goes out what happens if power
goes out in my building in the middle of
the winter I lose heat now you think oh
yeah because she has electrical heating
but I don't have electrical heating I
have I have I have water watered
radiators with the water actually the
hot water coming centrally the problem
is I have an electrical pump in my
basement
so did something happen to make us less
secure today in modern society or did it
just suddenly feel more likely and what
lessons can we learn from the mistrust
that is embedded in election security
make Diagnostics not depend on computers
have some way for people to observe
directly what is going on in your
physical system
be wary of single points of failure
segments your infrastructure is
something breaks down make sure it
doesn't spread and test manual
operations require physical presence and
that is a feature because it's much more
risky for people to be there in person
and figure out who are your most likely
threat actors and don't like care about
what's on TV like study history on the
other hand of course on July 10th 2019
Ukrainian Secret Service raided the
South Ukraine nuclear power plant so you
would think oh yeah they had a
cyberattack
you know nah employees at the Iranian
nuclear power plant connect the plans
Network to the internet so they can mine
cryptocurrency
I mean yeah so to finish off the talk I
guess we should talk about how what is
the best way to manipulate an election
just to get it off our chests so if you
want to rig your election if you're
sitting government and you want to make
sure you get reelected what is the
absolute way best way to go about that
internet voting thank you so much
[Applause]